avant tous vécu un moment important dans
la vie de la nation donc on va continuer
de travailler d'abord la première
réponse c'est l'ordre le calme les
saisies de mortiers d'artifice par la
police s'accumulent depuis le début des
émeutes rien qu'en région parisienne
c'est une tonne et demie d'artifice qui
a été saisie par les forces de l'ordre
une semaine la demande de remise en
liberté du policier qui a tiré sur Naël
à Nanterre a été rejetée décision ce
matin de la cour d'appel de Versailles
un premier rapport de l'IGPN dévoile des
éléments essentiels de l'enquête et les
déclarations du briquetier mises en
examen malheureusement des Français donc
des jeunes qui ont
une carte d'identité française sont
tentés par un repli communautaire comme
un retour vers les origines est-ce que
quand tu cries nique la France ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que même si tu as
ton passeport français tu es vraiment un
français de coeur ou un français de
papier c'est juste ça et il faut pas
jouer sur les mots de nombreux députés
nupestres crient au racisme décomplexé
c'est une formule ignoble qui atteste de
la régression vers les origines racistes
de l'auteur cette obsession des origines
atteste que cet homme ne comprend rien à
la conception républicaine de la
citoyenneté et de la nation mais il y a
eu beaucoup de Kevin et Matteo si je
peux me permettre
il y en a eu aussi et l'explication
n'est pas n'est pas
l'explication seulement identitaire me
paraît très erronée il s'agit pas de
tout abalgamer il y a sûrement des Kevin
et des Matéo mais posez la question au
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans une
commune qui a plus de 40 % de sa
population et qui est issu soit de
l'immigration soit directement de
l'immigration il faut regarder les
choses en face il y a une ultra majorité
de personnes qui ont participé à ces
émeutes qui sentent étrangers ou qui
sont d'origine étrangère et c'est le
problème de l'assimilation dans notre
pays de l'intégration
totale nous proposerons dans nos textes
l'accroissement et la diversification de
notre capacité carcérale avec un
objectif de 80 000 places de prison à
l'horizon 2027 je supprimerai le droit
du c'est à dire que à 18 ans la personne
qui est née en France de parents
étrangers devra demander la nationalité
française nous devons aussi quasiment
doublé le nombre de nos centres
éducatifs fermés si il a un CV
judiciaire long comme le bras il
n'obtiendra pas la nationalité française
nous devons être plus exigeants dans la
manière dont nous accordons la
nationalité des personnes interpellées
n'avaient pas de casier les suites de
l'affaire du fond Marianne le manque de
rigueur l'opacité et la désinvolture ont
conduit au fiasco a conclut la
commission d'enquête du Sénat avec
succès la nuit dernière un ultime
lancement après 27 ans de bons éloyaux
services sur place en Guyane ou à la
Cité de l'espace à Toulouse
l'enthousiasme était le même pour saluer
le 117e vol de la fusée le manque de
rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco deux plaintes vise
iromirolin proche d'Alain Delon depuis
de nombreuses années souvent décrite
comme sa dame de compagnie l'acteur
lui-même en parle comme sa compagne
japonaise en 2021 cette femme de 66 ans
vit depuis plusieurs années avec Alain
de Londres dans son domaine à Douchy
dans le Loiret elle est aujourd'hui
accusée par les enfants de la star de
couper volontairement le lien avec ses
proches au sommet de ce manège à 30
mètres de haut les passagers de ce
looping coincé la tête en bas au sol les
visiteurs de la fête foraine filment la
scène estomaqué
en se faisant passer pour lui elle tente
d'intercepter son courrier postal elle
empêche ses enfants de venir le voir
régulièrement comme ils l'ont pourtant
toujours fait elle se montre autoritaire
menaçante une plainte à laquelle s'est
joints Alain Delon lui-même par écrit la
première victime que l'on voit ici est
extraite au bout de deux heures sous les
applaudissements
la dernière plus de 3h30 après le début
de la panne encore inexpliquée scandale
à la Maison Blanche une mystérieuse
poudre blanche qui a été retrouvée et
après analyse c'est confirmé il s'agit
bien de cocaïne une enquête a été
ouverte pour déterminer qui a apporté la
drogue